[Music]
- okay
now last week we supposed to talk about
Janelle Charlie versus honey house
rematch part two you see when the first
fight jemelle Charlo lost a
controversial decision to Tony Harrison
when in that fight I had Jamel we're
winning
hey the two round go one round so 114
113 or 116 114 and that didn't happen so
20 Charles because is Jamal Charla
and this Jamel Charlie Jamal is the one
that fights in the highway class in the
middleweight division
Jamel is the one who fights in support
division now usually they're on the same
fight cards and I guess that can be a
bit distracting you know so he lost the
belt and useless fight sometimes
what happened was Tony Harrison came up
with an injury before the fight and
instead of being idle and sitting on
himself on the Shelf Jamel decided to
fight crota on a photo and not cut out a
third round right now
the twin Charles everybody likes the
problem does it get to you know
confusion to me tomorrow and you know
what we can use and stuff like that is
very easily to get confused with them
because they are identical place you
know they some difference is hearing it
you know they got tattoos to telling
apart but will you tell people you'll
give up your shirt in situation anyway
them the Charro's along with tank ages
and Earl Spencer jr. is the future of
boxing all right so you have to
understand that these guys are highly
avoided
and very rarely tested so it's very hard
to get to you guys to sharpening skills
now we're here to talk about the Jamaal
tarlowe fight
Jamaal Charlo his fighting Adams and
he's fighting in his hometown and he
doesn't have the distraction of having
his brother on his undercard all on the
main part all right cuz usually they
would have that distraction the
distraction is no longer there these
guys fight separately now because they
understand they have to be there for
each other in the corner and I get it I
would engage with you
push the wall motion around if my
brother was fighting on an undercard all
above me in the main attraction and I
had to suppress that and focus on my
fight that idea but I understand unity
and they saw that it was wrestling with
the destruction okay now let me preface
this in saying that the WBC has done the
best to hide a champion away from the
most destructive force that he can face
because we all know Jamal charlo who was
the mandatory for the WBC to fight
Canelo Alvarez Canelo Alvarez next fight
had to be against Ramallah darling well
what the WBC did was decided to give the
belt to Jamal Charles now he is the WBC
middleweight champion and they made no
outlets a franchise champion what the
hell is that
that is how to duck a brother and two
easy steps
give the belt to the guide your foot
second you don't need any bucks and any
face we make this guy a paper champion
listen we all know that Canelo is the
cash cow right now people's chasing I'm
pen is well-deserved
because the kid doesn't ducked anybody
and well you know he's a grown man now
he doesn't duck anybody he gets up and
he mixes it up and fights people that
people don't want him the fight oh he's
a closer did you say that he's supposed
to be afraid to fight and his dad goes
out and gives you 110% remember his
first and only loss and my opinion was a
full-fledged law school the greatest
boxer of our generation Floyd Mayweather
the money all right so just understand
this fight with Adams that Charlo is
going to do right now it's a formality
basically you know he's fighting in his
hometown to be distracted we will not
take anything for granted you know as
far as new media we argue media right so
I took that fight for granted with
Joshua fight in the West called it a
hamburger fight and I didn't want to
call it
see listen man this channel isn't full
reporting news and all this other stuff
I don't get into
give you what I choose to watch and what
I choose a report on and how you gonna
bet your dollars and whatever you do
with it what box and knowledge that I
can give you now Jamal Charlo reminds me
of Terry Norris not old Terry Larson I
want you to go back in the box and
history look up some awesome
none you just started watching box and
then this is the channel that you fell
in love for food I want you to go watch
Terry Norris but he has something that
Terry Norris didn't have he has a chin
and Terry Norris had better boxing
ability but Jamal charlo and Jamel
Charla needs to do is work on that jab
they have the ferocity they have the
power they have the determination what
they need to do is work on that jab in
every fight that they have with the
superuser out one day he does get a
chance to get on Canelo in the ring I
hope one day he does get a chance to
show you all this Wiz but I doubt that
ever happened because him you'll see
another loss functionals record I know
people say triple G was supposed to be
Canelo and I honestly believe that
Canelo be triple G and bull fights that
they had and he beat them gonna decide
and victory in the second fight and I
don't think a third fight will manifest
itself because I believe that your Fuji
is Declan people and no one cares for
that when everybody's out here fighting
as hard as possible so I got Jamal
charlo 186
if I give Adams you know
chance he's a good boxes and slick boxer
and his stuff from side to side he can
give me some angles you can make it a
little bit rough in there sometimes when
he has to be but he's in there with a
lion my mother this is Lions only that's
between Charles model lions home they
hunting pack and rolling pack and there
to you up to pieces it's time bad talk
with the king and the next fight you get
from me is Pacquiao or star me boy you
do not want to miss my breakdown and
analysis of old the Pacquiao vs. move
Thurman catch you next time
[Music]